dares we're going to start off fresh
from last game you know everybody wants
to love to talk about your points and
assists I want to go right to clutch I
think that's where you've taken a
Quantum Leap of being that leader talk
about making a play in clutch time um I
think they trust me and they look at me
uh to to to finish games and when I got
traded here I was kind of thrust into
that role and I was not prepared for it
how do you prepare for that on the court
film work obviously first and foremost I
think just watching out the best of the
best finish games guys like Steph guys
like Luca guys like Braun KD book like
the guys who can finish games the right
way the possessions at the end like they
have more juice to them and so just
using my brain and my IQ put our team in
good spots to get the best shot possible
and uh feel like I've I've been able to
pick my spots very
well off Bal
three Cur into the pain of beautyy is
putting it getting
high that's a shake them up with style
so efficient as a young player you know
the last two games the points the
assists and no turnovers you know I'm a
big fan of that the efficiency and I
know as a competitor you want that with
those numbers right yeah for sure just
trying to get good shots and then have
trust in my shots as a point guard my
job is to make sure that we're getting
good looks every every time down the
floor whether that's for myself or for
my teammates so I feel like if I get a
good look I'm going to make more than
I'm going to miss you know so the
efficiency just comes with getting the
right looks and taking the right shots
the Indiana Pacers number one offense in
the NBA look how fast Indiana gets down
the floor here comes Halton Alberton to
Turner Turner throws it down Alberton
nice tyes help me I played against Rick
Carl's teams slow methodical where is
this coming from if you guys went in
there and say hey let us run more give
me this because the Rick car out teams
I've played against has been a grimy
grit Rick has done a good job of I think
adapting to you guys for sure I think
obviously his experience with great
players Durk and Luca I think when I got
traded here we met right away and he was
like listen I don't want to call plays
anymore you take it that's just
ultimately down to the relationship and
the trust that we have in each other and
I think that he's just allowing who I am
as a player to uh flow within our
organization and I think everybody
appreciate that and it looks fun for
people they they look at that and
they're like man that's something I'd
want to I'd want to play for and some I
hate playing against so um I think we're
building a great culture within our
organization Albert looking for an
opening how
about it's the dribble penetration of
halberton 15 assists for Tyrese
halberton and boy he is delivering once
you get that level of confidence it's
hard to kind of push it away and you
talk about competing this in season
tournament talk to me about the
competition level it seems like
everybody's taking this to another level
how has it been everybody talks about
the money right but I also think like
it's the NBA like we got the best
competitors in the world competing for
something and um I think that's the
great part about it and that's why I've
loved it cuz we all NBA players we all
have money I want to win because I want
to say I did it and nobody else did you
know what I mean I'm a competitor first
I didn't I didn't play basketball for
money that's not why I do it like I play
basketball because I love this and I
want to be a winner so I think that's
been the great thing and it's been a lot
of fun for everybody
[Applause]
involved